I was so angered uh to see that all the
places because obviously a lot of places
I adore didn't survive covid you would
think after a year there'd be healing
like people would be returning you know
what I mean like I would say like a
quarter of the storefronts were
unoccupied there was not this enthusiasm
in the air
um there was really no place that I
wanted to go necessarily it is not
fertile soil to have a Renaissance
anymore and that is something that even
pre-giuliani I'd never experienced in my
lifetime New York's crime era people
don't realize it was an opportunity
because if you were like a poor artist
who can handle living in dangerous
streets you could still get an apartment
and you could still go there and create
and make a scene and the rents are too
high for that and everything else is too
difficult you're not going to be a
cultural magnet as you were you know 23
or you know 30 years ago in the 70s when
you know the punk scene was there
foreign
so let's talk about that because I
haven't had you on for a while I still
lived in that crazy LA and you still
lived in that crazy Brooklyn so we both
made Moves since we last sat down about
a year and a half ago
um I take it you're happier in Texas
than you were in New York I didn't
remember how I didn't realize how lonely
New York had gotten towards the end yeah
um it was like Survivor one by one of my
friends I don't mean people I've seen at
parties just people I like talk to a
regular basis moved away they they you
know you're playing poker at a certain
point like I'm out yeah unfold I have
just like a couple of friends left in
New York the majority of them moved to
Austin and to be able to have a social
group is something that is wonderful New
Yorkers are told a lie and I believe
this my entire life which is you know
these people who move out in New York oh
they're weak they can't hack it and at a
certain point it does become like Atlas
Shrugged Iron Man's book it's like why
am I carrying this burden like what what
is my upside here so I could stand up
and say look how tough I am a New Yorker
no one's ever going to perceive me as
tough well there was a time where that
had value right it's a short time when
the toughness and the culture was there
but it just simply isn't there anymore I
went back over the summer I hadn't been
there for a whole year because Tim Poole
put up a billboard in me and Times
Square I'm like oh I gotta say the
person right this is bucket list
literally put you up in in the times
where your face Tim cast looking down at
the dresses as is my destiny and
I was so angered uh to see that all the
places because obviously a lot of places
I adore didn't survive covid you would
think after a year there'd be healing
like people would be returning you know
what I mean like I would say like a
quarter of the storefronts were
unoccupied there was not this enthusiasm
in the air there was really no place
that I wanted to go necessarily it is
not fertile soil to have a Renaissance
anymore and that is something that even
pre-giuliani I'd never experienced in my
lifetime New York's crime era people
don't realize it was an opportunity
because if you were like a poor artist
who can handle living in dangerous
streets you could still get an apartment
and you could still go there and create
and make a scene yeah and the rents are
too high for that and everything else is
too difficult you're not going to be a
cultural magnet as you were you know 23
or you know 30 years ago in the 70s when
you know the punk scene was so what do
you think happens to New York City
because to me it has not hit rock bottom
yet I agree the times that I've been
there in the last two years it's more
depressing each time there were no
people doing business that's what I
always notice even in Midtown so I've
gone for Gutfeld you know so fox is
right in the middle of Midtown it's
supposed to be people in suits that's
what you used to see groups of guys in
suits going to lunch and doing business
now it's just people in hoodies all
walking alone everyone looks like
they're up to no good and the whole
place smells like weed and I'm not
against weed as a general rule and I
know you're certainly not against making
it illegal right but it shouldn't the
your business center shouldn't smell
like weed all day it's kind of scary
that having my face in Times Square is
in Rock Bottom I would have thought this
is as low as we get but apparently the
basement has a Cellar yeah and the the
crime and it's just something that I
remember as a kid you know kind of in
the background because I was much
younger but to have that kind of sense
of the thing that I think is the worst
part is there doesn't seem to be any
will or plan to turn it around now if if
mayor Adams was like let's try this
let's try that or governor kokel was
saying you know this is our plan to kind
of have a lot of faith in her but
they're not even identifying issues
they're just kind of being like oh
you're just making this up for
propaganda purpose New York is safer
than ever it's just like okay if people
don't feel safe that in and of itself is
a problem so why are they misperceeding
in your opinion uh this lack of safety
so a guy like you who strikes me you're
such a New Yorker like yes in the best
sense of that I mean that so you go to
Texas now you're in Austin which
obviously is a blue City in a red State
um culture shock or did you just kind of
just get there and you're good to go
well it's kind of cute because some
people come at me they're like you moved
to the San Francisco of Texas I'm like
yeah the key word here is of Texas this
is not needles on the street right uh
like complete Chessa Boudin district
attorney kind of situation it's still
very Texan uh in itself but there is
there's a pretty decent homeless problem
no we had a referendum they cleaned them
up so they and they took it it's not
like no no it's not like back in La no
they used to be like la like the entire
Street was tense I don't know where they
went
um I I don't don't really care at this
point but it I mean because you had it
was really really bad you could I
visited during covet I was doing Rogan
and I wanted to go get ice cream and I'd
take an Uber a few blocks because the
streets were completely deserted and the
only people on the streets were like
literal junkies I'm like this is not a
good uh look for me this is not going to
end well for me but now it's it's it's
just absolutely I'm just very very happy
the fact that I can own a gun in my own
home uh is just just wonderfully
reassuring because in New York you know
I have cool stuff I put Instagram
sometimes if someone breaks into my
house I can't defend myself or I'm going
to jail they'll be much more likely to
prosecute someone who defends their home
with a gun than someone who breaks into
the house now you know I if someone
comes to my someone comes to my house
even if they're my friend I can shoot
them and it's Texas and I'll have no
repercussions come on over Dave if they
are coming for your Blanche de Avro
negligee they are gonna get a bullet in
their ass it covers it exactly covers
the perky bosom what is it about Austin
that keeps it blue in a red state so a
state that's pretty functional that's
making sense and everything else and
then and then there is this there's
artists there obviously it's just a
different thing what is the blue text
well I I think what is that yeah I think
conservas always talk about like oh
these are the um policies and all these
democrat-run cities there are no
republican-run cities if you look at the
top 20 cities of a population I think
Miami is the only one with the
Republican mayor so cities are
historically run by democrats and
there's a lot of reasons one of the
biggest reasons is if you're living
shoulder to shoulder with people you
have to have this liberal probably more
classical liberal sense of like Live and
Let Live because you can't really be in
each other's business if you're just
kind of this close you have to kind of
make these sacrifice in terms of being a
busybody
um and some blue cities are obviously
run very differently than others there's
a reason San Francisco can afford to
have these massive rents you know as
Detroit you're selling houses for a
dollar or Baltimore it is another one or
New York versus LA there's different
metrics that go into it
um it's so it's not at all to me uh blue
in the sense that La was blue we're not
people are wearing masks they're not
having these stupid virtue signaling
signs lines in the windows of the stores
and I feel like Austin I think more than
Miami and I I I bet you'd agree with me
has become this kind of Beacon for
people who are refugees within America
like a lot more than Miami why more than
Miami because I'm seeing the beacon is
freaking bright over here there may not
be a perfect way to quantify it but I
feel like Austin has more scenes than
Miami does so we have like the Bitcoin
people the the um we've got the Bitcoin
people hold on hold on people very
defensive we've got here we've got a
bigger stand-up comedy center field in
New York we've got a bigger podcast
scene I think the New York
um are we talking about Miami Miami
there's a biohacker community Whole
Foods started so there's a whole white
people stuff uh thing happening in
Austin
no but you don't have Whole Foods
culture you know what I mean like that
stuff white people like where you're
just trying to go to you know the spa
and you do the cold plunge and then
you're rock climbing all that stuff
absolutely you know I find anathema so I
feel like that kind of thing is more and
I think Miami has more history than
Austin Miami's been a city for a lot
longer as a major city than Austin has
so Austin is in some ways finding its
own character now as opposed to Miami's
has always been like a party town right
and we're not a party town right I'm in
The Burbs it's very yeah exactly your
dad there's this I'm a dad there's
lizards it's all very pleasant you know
when it gets cold you know iguanas fall
out of the sky yeah
like they go unconscious and yeah yeah
there was an iguana you got problems
it's not what's the problem it's the
iguana's got a problem
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell